sort of related to the last question but
not really hey David do you think Donald
Trump's going to invade Venezuela so the
back there's a couple backstories on
this one is that we learned that at a
certain point in our earlier in Trump's
presidency I believe in 2017
he was asking aides about what would a
plan to invade Venezuela look like so
the idea has certainly been in his head
this has been reinvigorated by the chaos
that's currently taking place in
Venezuela where the quote re-elected
president Nicolas Maduro in what appears
to have been a completely fraudulent
election has been called into question
by the head of the National Assembly
guai though who is trying to be interim
president until there can be fair
election so in the midst of this Donald
Trump has come out and said he supports
the interim president and now the
question once again is well would there
be an interest in in Donald Trump of by
Donald Trump in invading Venezuela at
any point I do think that Trump might
look for someone to invade to take
attention away from his crimes and his
failure as president so at sort of the
macro level it's pretty reasonable based
on what we know about Trump to consider
whether he might try such military
action I think that most of Trump's
inner circle knows that it would be a
disaster to get involved in Venezuela I
believe that they would do everything
possible to prevent another one of these
disastrous American military involvement
in Latin America which have been train
wrecks for decades but I do believe
there is a chance Donald Trump will push
if he gets desperate enough to take
military action in Venezuela because he
might imagine that it would unite the
u.s. that Americans would be sort of
overwhelmingly behind getting Maduro
fully out in Venezuela and of course the
problem with invading Venezuela versus a
place like Iraq aside from all of the
legal questions as to what whether it
would be legal to take such such action
is that Americans simply don't see
Venezuela
threat to the united states i'm as
against nicolas maduro as really as
anyone could be I'm not an authoritarian
extremist i want democracy and voting
and free press and free courts so I'm a
huge opponent of Nicolas Maduro
but Venezuela is not even ostensibly a
threat to the United States in any
traditional sense
I was against military action in Iraq
but there was at least a case that could
be made that it was imperative to
American national security to go into
Iraq I think it was a case we know now
it was a case based on trumped up in
faulty intelligence but you could at
least convince some Americans with that
I don't even know how you convince
Americans that it makes sense to send
troops to Venezuela for national
security reasons so I think that yes
Trump might do it but I don't believe
that it will ultimately be useful
politically to him and there are a whole
bunch of other things that Trump might
do that would be equally crazy and meant
to distract from the disaster after
disaster that that is Trump's presidency
if you disagree with me on this one let
me know I want to hear from you